we are witnessing
how russia is weaponizing its energy
supplies
we must now reduce as soon as possible
our dependency on russian fossil fuels
with repower eu we show that we can
replace russian fossil fuels by working
on three levels
the first level is saving energy simple
but very effective on the supply side
it's of course diversifying away from
russia for fossil fuels
and towards other reliable trustworthy
suppliers
and the most important part
accelerating the clean energy
transitions so massive investment in
renewable energy the climate cannot wait
but now
the geopolitical reasons are evident too
we have to diversify away from fossil
fuels
the renewable energy has the big
advantage that it is not only good for
the climate
but it is also good for our independence
and good for our security of supply and
it creates jobs at home
this whole
approach is repower eu we are mobilizing
up to 300 billion euros
to save more energy
to accelerate the phasing out of fossil
fuel
and most importantly to kick-start
investments on a new scale we know that
when europe acts together
it has more clout